corona gipfel abgesagt nun will der bund
zusammen mit den ländern einheitliche
regeln per gesetz durchsetzen lockdown
stadt lockerungen fordern
intensivmediziner um die steigenden
zahlen an patienten und toten zu senken
trauer und prinz philip der loyaler
weggefährte und ehemann der queen stirbt
im alter von 99 jahren
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend wir kommen bei
heute hier im zweiten aber lehmann
versorgt und später mit dem wichtigsten
vom sport und wohnen doch bevor wir
gleich zur corona politik kommen erst
noch ein kurzer blick über den kanal ins
trauernde großbritannien dort ist prinz
philip er heute morgen auf schloss
winter gestorben im hundertsten
lebensjahr eine nachricht die nicht ganz
überraschend kam aber doch viele
bestürzt
bereits seit dem frühen nachmittag
kommen menschen zum buckingham palace
sie legen blumen nieder
wegen der korona pandemie versucht die
polizei ein grösseres gedränge zu
verhindern
doch die briten bildern weiter zum
palast
und dort steht auch unsere
korrespondentin diana zimmermann die
gerne wie groß ist denn die anteilnahme
in dieser schwierigen zeit
die briten hatten ein
dreivierteljahrhundert zeit sich an
prinz philipp zu gewöhnen und viele
haben in dieser zeit sehr lieb gewonnen
die sind heute natürlich sehr traurig
und lassen sich auch nicht so recht von
der bitte des palastes abbringen hierher
zu kommen und von öffentlichen
beileidsbekundungen abzusehen
ein paar hundert heute waren eigentlich
immer dort um blumen für den herzog von
edinburgh niederzulegen
ihm selber würde diese reduzierte form
von trauer sicherlich gut gefallen haben
denn er sagte er fände er sei zu
unwichtig als dass sein tod größere
feierlichkeiten hervorziehen bringt
hervorbringen sollte
vielen dank eines zweiten diana wir
sprechen uns später in der sendung
wieder wo wir noch ausführlicher auf den
tod von prinz philip eingeben wollen
danke aber zunächst nach deutschland und
zur corona krise der haben bund und
länder ihr geplantes treffen am montag
abgesagt stattdessen haben sie sich
darauf geeinigt das
infektionsschutzgesetz zu ändern
so sollen künftig für landkreise mit
hohem incidents werten bundesweit
einheitliche regelungen gelten ab einer
inzidenz von 100 gebe es dann eine
nächtliche ausgangssperre läden würden
wieder geschlossen
ab einer inzidenz von über 200 müssten
dann auch die schulen wieder schließen
klaus brodbeck berichtet
jetzt übernimmt es doch der bund zwei
tage telefonierten kanzlerin und
vizekanzler mit den ländern
und dass carola durcheinander der
vergangenen tage zu ordnen
es macht sind diese situation aufzulösen
durch eine klare regelung von der alle
wissen wie sie jetzt die nächste zeit in
der pandemie sein wird dann muss man
auch nicht alle zwei wochen darüber neu
verhandeln
da muss auch nicht jeden tag jemand ein
neues interview geben um zu verkünden
was als nächstes zu tun ist auch der
bundestag wird damit stärker eingebunden
als bisher
das fordern abgeordnete und fraktionen
seit monaten
wir benötigen einen radikalen
wellenbrecher wir benötigen
einheitlichkeit und rechtssicherheit und
deswegen ist es gut und längst
überfällig dass der deutsche bundestag
mit dem bundesrat entscheidet alles was
zur senkung der zahlen führt was zur
entlastung der intensiv medizin führt
das werden wir mittragen aber das darf
auf gar keinen fall dazu führen dass die
eigentlichen aufgaben nämlich eine
beschleunigung beim impfen eine
verbesserung bei den tests dass das
etwas nicht geschieht wenn tatsächlich
schon bei einer instanz von 100 neue
infektionen pro woche sogar über
ausgangssperren nachgedacht wird und
alle modellprojekte um zum beispiel mit
tests handle oder außengastronomie zu
ermöglichen eingestellt werden
dann wäre das also unserer sicht
unverhältnismäßig wenn die länder
tatsächlich mitmachen könnte die
gesetzesänderung schnell gehen wenn wie
ernst die lage ist das lässt sich vor
allem auf den intensivstationen
beobachten
dort kämpfen derzeit immer mehr corona
patienten um ihr leben
waren es vor einer woche noch 3839
menschen sind es heute gut 4500 das sind
662 mehr zudem gibt es knapp 300 neue
todesfälle
auch das mehr als vergangenen freitag
die warnungen der mediziner innen werden
immer eindringlicher mischa
was wenn man hilfe braucht und im
krankenhaus ist kein intensiv bett mehr
frei
erste städte wie köln bonn und bremen
melden dass sie kaum noch kapazitäten
haben wie schon im dezember
damals mussten intensiv patientinnen auf
krankenhäuser in andere regionen
verteilt werden
aktuell gibt es in deutschland weniger
als 3000 freie intensivbetten pro
krankenhaus sind das noch 1,5 betten und
da müssen wir nicht nur profit 19
patienten versorgen sondern jeden herz
und tag jeden schlaganfall jeden akuten
bauch und das ist wirklich wirklich
knapp normalerweise sagt man man
burkhard eine 80-prozentige auslastung
um um handlungsfähig zu sein
das haben wir schon lange verlassen nach
ostern sind die infektionszahlen
zunächst gesunken
einige ministerpräsidenten hatten das
positiv interpretiert und sich gegen
einen lock down ausgesprochen
eine falsche einschätzung kritisiert der
chef des rk ii
dann kann es doch nicht sein dass man
sich durch einige niedrige zahl über
einige tage irritieren lässt sondern wir
sehen ja dass die zahlen wachsen und ich
will das noch mal sagen
der einzige wirkliche echtzeit indikator
den wir haben und da bin ich sehr
dankbar für das wir das glaube ich im
april letzten jahres gesetzlich geregelt
haben das intensivbetten register da
brauchen wir jetzt nicht drumherum zu
reden oder zu diskutieren
jens spahn fordert einen harten doktor
um die dritte welle zu brechen und auch
um das klinikpersonal zu schützen wollen
wir warten bis 10.000 sowas ist in die
logik wenn wir warten bis es wollen wir
die grenze austesten wollen was einmal
austesten was das land kann in einer
notsituation in der intensivstation
jeder tag den wir später handeln
verlieren wir menschen leben ganz klar
die botschaft ist eindeutig eine antwort
der politik steht noch aus ja und diese
antwort wäre ja dann ein überarbeitetes
infektionsschutzgesetz container
banerjee in berlin wird das denn jetzt
funktionieren und wie schnell kann es
überhaupt kommen also zumindest
demonstrieren heute alle beteiligten
gemeinsam dass sie da sehr
zuversichtlich sind und senden das
signal das die bundeseinheitliche
notbremse ein wichtiges mittel wäre um
schnell zu reagieren
sie könnte wenn sie denn kommt die
monatlichen sitzungen von bund und
ländern ersetzen die zuletzt nötig waren
wenn man jedes mal über neue massnahmen
entscheiden wollte und damit auch das
streitpotenzial etwas verringern
die frage ist nur eben wird man sich
tatsächlich darauf einigen und kommt es
jetzt so reibungslos wie heute die
beteiligten hier den anschein machen
denn da steht noch einiges bevor die
bundesregierung drückt auf jeden fall
aufs tempo sie möchte am dienstag einen
tag als sonst üblich das kabinett
zusammen rufen und dort schon den
gesetzesvorschlag durchbringen
und dann soll es ein beschleunigtes
gesetzgebungsverfahren im bundestag
geben und im bundesrat darauf hofft man
zumindest da muss man dann aber die
opposition mitnehmen und die
bundesländer mitnehmen und da könnte es
dann doch noch mal zu
auseinandersetzungen kommen weil es vor
allem um die frage gehen wird wie weit
kann diese notbremse eingreifen kann sie
zum beispiel auch schul und kita
schließungen beinhalten da wird es noch
einige auseinandersetzungen geben und
diejenigen die es auf eine sofortige
notbremsung gehofft haben die müssen
sich noch ein bisschen gedulden
vielen dank für die einordnung unterleib
energy gute nachrichten beim thema
impfen knapp 700 20.000 menschen haben
gestern hierzulande eine impfdosis
bekommen ein neuer rekord insgesamt sind
das 17 millionen erst und zweitwohnungen
doch gleichzeitig steigen die korona
zahlen das robert koch institut meldet
heute 25 1464 neuinfektionen binnen
eines tages das sind rund 3500 fälle
mehr als vor einer woche
die sieben tage incidents steigt auf
110,4 wegen der osterferien sind die
zahlen jedoch nur bedingt aussagekräftig
sorge bereitet weiter die lage an den
schulen wie soll der schutz vor den
kurven virus am wirksamsten hergestellt
werden im präsenz wechsel oder im
distanz unterricht diese frage wird in
den bundesländern sehr unterschiedlich
beantwortet nur tests gibt es überall
die lage zum schulstart nach ostern fast
farblos
die lage zusammen wenn am montag in neun
bundesländern die schule wieder losgeht
steht für viele als allererstes ein
corona selbst test auf dem stundenplan
allerdings ist der nur in zwölf
bundesländern auch verpflichtend in vier
ländern ist er freiwillig den lehrern
ist das nicht genug
deswegen setzen wir darauf dass diese
schnelltests auch flecken flächendeckend
kommen und zwar verpflichtend und selbst
da wo die testpflicht gilt gibt es große
unterschiede
in bayern gilt bei einer sieben tage
inzidenz unter 100 wechsel unterricht
über 100 heißt erneut distanz unterricht
in mecklenburg vorpommern gilt bei einer
inzidenz unter 150 präsenzunterricht bis
zur sechsten klasse der rest wechselt
sich ab
über 150 heißt distanz lernen zumindest
in einer frage sind sich die länder
einig die schulen sollen so lange wie
möglich offen bleiben das regelmäßige
testen der schüler und schülerinnen gilt
also als wesentliche maßnahme um die
sicherheit in den klassenzimmern zu
erhöhen
jetzt sind auch genügend schnelltests
vorhanden doch es hakt noch in der
praxis an agoda hat sich das in
rheinland-pfalz angeschaut hier hat er
unterricht schon angefangen heute auf
dem lehrplan der 2b wie geht ein corona
selbsttest
ab montag sollen sich die kinder der
martinus grundschule in mainz selbst
testen doch offene fragen und eine
gewisse verunsicherung bleibe eine frank
realschule plus ebenfalls in mainz die
klasse 6e ist schon weiter sie haben die
ersten test kits erhalten und legen los
man hat halt dann wenn man negativ ist
ein besseres gefühl zurück an der
martinusschule hier bereiten sie sich
auf montag vor und wünschen sich mehr
verbindlichkeit
es wäre sinnvoll in rheinland pfalz in
den schulen eine testpflicht einzuführen
weil wenn nur die eine hälfte der klasse
sich testen lässt und die andere nicht
unhinterfragt sich so ein bisschen die
sinnhaftigkeit ob dann überhaupt das
ergebnis repräsentativ ist und ob es nur
sicherheit wird wenn es nicht dazu
kommen dass sich 100 prozent der kinder
auf testen lassen am ende dann müssten
wir noch mal überlegen was kann der weg
sein aber wir sind auch davon überzeugt
dass die allermeisten eltern
dementsprechend agieren
eins steht fest die zeit die für das
testen aufgewendet wird geht von der eh
schon knappen unterrichtszeit ab durch
die hausärzte hat die impfkampagne
hierzu lange spürbar an fahrt
aufgenommen
was weiter fehlt ist eine ausreichende
menge impfstoff so verhandelt die
bundesregierung nun auch über den kauf
von sputnik wie das problem noch ist die
russische antwort auf cobit 19 in der eu
nicht zugelassen und viele auch in
russland fragen sich kann man's budnik
wie überhaupt vertrauen aus moskau
christiansen
hunderte beim live konzert ihrer
lieblingsband in russland kein problem
oder ein entspannter kneipen oder
restaurantbesuch kein lockdown trotz
wieder steigender infektionszahlen aber
die sorglosigkeit ist hier noch
ansteckender als das virus
ich habe schon antikörper darum habe ich
keine angst mehr
wir haben es schon überstanden der preis
für so viel freizügigkeit in pandemie
zeiten eine hohe über sterblichkeit wer
sich in moskau mit sputnik wie impfen
lassen will kann das fast überall machen
im luxuskaufhaus im fußballstadion sogar
in der oper und trotzdem haben erst 5,7
prozent der bevölkerung die erste dosis
sputnik bekommen viele sind skeptisch
das ist nicht geprüft wir wissen nicht
was da alles drin ist wie unser körper
darauf reagiert russland schickt derweil
seinen impfstoff in die welt 59 länder
haben ihn bereits registriert aber
russland kommt mit der produktion nicht
hinterher
auch deutschland will jetzt sputnik wie
und viele fragen sich was es von dem
vector impfstoff zu halten als ihre
logen das habe ich ja schon mehrfach
geäußert ich gemacht die idee für die
zwei impfungen zwei unterschiedliche
vektoren zu verwenden sicher gut
ob europa sputnik wie tatsächlich
zulässt ist noch ungewiss
im kreml jedenfalls ist man stolz auf
den russischen impfstoff dass er als
nebenwirkung nach für politischen streit
in europa sorgt kommt sehr gelegen
zurück zu prinz philip sein leben stand
im dienst der krone sein platz war an
der seite und doch stets im schatten
seiner frau heute morgen ist prinz
philip friedlich eingeschlafen erklärte
der palast
das vereinigte königreich trauert die
botschaft im hauptstadt himmel über
london seine königliche hoheit mögen sie
in frieden
jasin herlein klickt zurück
prinz philip herzog von edinburgh
pflichtbewusste und unermüdlicher
repräsentant der krone
für die einen war schlichter ehemann der
königin für andere der vielleicht meist
unterschätzte mann grossbritanniens am
juni 1921 wurde philipp aktionen des
prinzen andreas von griechenland und der
hessischen prinzessin alice von
battenberg auf korfu geboren
doch die ehe seiner eltern zerbrach
philipp wurde zu seinem onkel lord
mountbatten nach england geschickt und
machte dort rasch karriere in der
britischen marine bereits mit 13 jahren
so heißt es soll sich die junge
elisabeth unsterblich in den smarten
offizier verliebt haben ihrer verlobung
folgte 1947 die vielumjubelte hochzeit
philip heiratete die damals vielleicht
begehrteste junge frau der welt nach
elizabeths krönung nur fünf jahre später
musste der prinz seine laufbahn in der
marine aufgeben er übernahm die
verantwortung bei der erziehung der
kinder und stand hunderten von
wohltätigen organisationen als
schirmherr vor als mahner ökologischen
bewusstseins war er seiner zeit voraus
ich sehe nicht wie wir weiter
wirtschaftliches wachstum haben können
ohne stärker auf die umwelt zu achten
[Musik]
mit den medien hatte der prinz öfter so
seine probleme begierig laute die presse
auf den nächsten ausrutscher und
versprecher oder auch manch bewusste
provokation philipp war immer für eine
schlagzeile gut
2017 im alter von 96 jahren trat er in
den ruhestand nur selten sah man den
prinzen nun noch in der öffentlichkeit
die briten werden ihn vermissen die
fahnen auf halbmast überall im land und
die blumen die viele trotz chor ohne
auflagen vor schloss windsor niederlegen
bezeugen dies ja nochmal zu diana wie
wichtig war prinz philip für das
königshaus
er war natürlich der vater der
königlichen familie zu hause so hieß es
immer gab er den ton an
er hat sich aber auch für das königshaus
verdienst gemacht weil er ist im ganzen
land repräsentiert hat bei vielen
tausend terminen
er war sozial sehr engagiert er hat sich
vor einigen für jugendliche eingesetzt
und er hat sich für den umweltschutz
eingesetzt als das noch in keinster
weise üblich war
vor allem aber war natürlich der
wichtige partner der queen
er hat sie in allen dingen unterstützt
und so ist es auch heute so dass viele
briten sich sorgen welchen effekt sein
tod auf die bald 95-jährige haben wird
zumal die familie in einem großen streit
mit harry und megan ist und das land von
der pandemie und dragset unter schwerem
druck steht tatsächlich schwierige
zeiten vielen dank diana werner
zimmermann in london war das zum tode
von prinz viele zeigen wir gleich im
anschluss an diese sendung eine
dokumentation prinz philip ein leben für
die queen und auch in unserer zdf heute
app würdigen wir prinz philip dazu gibt
es weltweite reaktionen auf den tod des
starken mannes hinter der kuhn und nun
zum sport und da geht es mal nicht nur
im fußball sondern auch hat gestern
abend die finalserie um die deutsche
meisterschaft begonnen best of five
maximal fünf spiele gibt's da und zwar
zwischen berlin und friedrichshafen
die männer aus der hauptstadt gewann am
bodensee in einem hochdramatischen match
mit 3 zu 2
freude und erleichterung bei den berlin
volleys sie hatten dass spieler in einem
satz rückstand noch gedreht der dauer
rivale aus friedrichshafen deutsche
rekordchampion und erst danach der
hauptrunde china einen klaren sieg
anzusteuern 2 0 hieß es nach sätzen
doch berlin kam zurück satzausgleich und
im tie-break wehrten die gäste zunächst
zwei friedrichshafener matchbälle ab
nutzten dann selbst ihren dritten die
beiden dominanten deutschen clubs sind
auf augenhöhe
die finalserie best of five könnte lange
spannend verlaufen
münchen droht das aus als gastgeber der
fußball em im sommer die uefa hat die
zwölf austragungsstädte aufgefordert den
besuch von zuschauern zuzusichern
münchen hatte das bislang nicht getan
und muss sich jetzt bis zum 19 april
definitiv äußern
morgen das bundesliga-topspiel frankfurt
gegen wolfsburg der tabellenvierte gegen
den -dritten es geht um die champions
league plätze für den gewinner wäre das
ticket für die königsklasse zum greifen
nah sie haben gut lachen wolfsburg und
frankfurt hoch hinaus richtung champions
league das ziel meiner rom blicken sowie
der will wo es tun sie das auch tun aber
die chance und die möglichkeit mit einem
sieg einen punkt haben wohl es so gerade
zu rücken und das ist das klare ziel
auch wir haben sehr viel selbstvertrauen
auch wir haben jetzt auswärts das eine
oder andere spiel gewonnen und deswegen
ja wir freuen uns riesig werden richtig
cooles spiel beiden läuft unruhig ist in
frankfurt der trainer vermeidet ein
bekenntnis zum verbleib dass es viele
menschen interessiert ist ökologisch
aber haben auf der anderen seite ich
weiß nicht ob man immer etwas dazu sagen
muss das wichtigste ist mir dass ich
mich auf das wesentliche konzentrieren
liga dritter gegen vierter es geht um
die auftritte auf europas ganz großer
bühne
wolfsburg stürmer wird welche rost ist
morgen gast im aktuellen sportstudio 3
139 banken arbeit gerne das
wochenendwetter bietet kräftigen regen
und große temperaturgegensätze mehr dazu
gleich von özden terli so viel von uns
mehr gibt es im heute journal um 10 mit
claus kleber morgen um 7 sind wir wieder
dran jetzt aber erst mal einen
entspannten freitagabend für sie
[Musik]
ein schöner abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter warme luft
erreicht hauptsächlich allerdings den
süden deutschlands unterweisen auch
ziemlich viele wolken mit kräftigem
regen der uns morgen im tagesverlauf
nach nordosten hin überquert ganz im
norden da kommt kalte luft an
schauen wir uns das im detail an von
südwesten her also viele wolken mit
kräftigen regen der langsam richtung
nordosten zieht ganz im norden lockert
es auf und auch im südosten der funken
teilweise die sterne temperaturen sinkt
dabei auf 9 grad im rhein-main-gebiet
und minus ein grad als es am kältesten
in schleswig holstein
ja und morgen im tagesverlauf zieht der
regen weiter besonders im westen regnet
es kräftig und langsam richtung
nordosten
an den küsten gibt es aber sonnenschein
und auch nach südosten und süden hin und
das bei temperaturen bis 15 teils 19
grad im südwesten
hier deutlich wärmer als im norden mit
temperaturen von sieben bis neun grad
die kommenden tage temperaturen kontrast
ist noch grösser am sonntag 20 grad im
südosten 5 grad an der küste und dazu
kräftiger regen ja unter ab montag
schwenkt die kaltluft dann von
nordwesten her nach süden durch und im
süden gibt es regen und schnee ein
schöner ab